et je reçois à présent pour cette
édition du 78 an ce 13 juin Valérie
rochour bonsoir vous êtes fondatrice de
la maison d'édition plume en herbe
bonsoir et félicitations également
puisque vous venez de recevoir le Prix
PEP 78 est décerné par les collégiens et
également les élèves de CM2 de
l'académie de Versailles pour un ouvrage
un roman fantastique le chateteau de
1000 pertuies PEP 78 ce sont les
Pupilles de l'enseignement public des
evelines un prix qui est soutenu par
l'Agence nationale de lutte contre
l'ilérisme ce prix représente quoi pour
vous ah c'est beaucoup de satisfaction
aller à la rencontre des enfants savoir
qu'ils ont eu du plaisir à rentrer dans
cette histoire un peu fantastique et
avoir des retours chaleureux le travail
des enseignants aussi oui ça quels sont
les critères d'attribution de de ce prix
de cette récompense qui est soutenue par
l'Agence Nationale de Lutte contre
l'ilétrisme alors sans doute ça permet
de c'est une opération qui permet de de
de lutter contre l'ilétrisme alors c'est
effectivement le but du P 78 c'està-dire
qu'ils ont sont rendu compte que au
niveau national mais plus spécifiquement
sur les Yveline il y avait quand même un
nombre très élevé de personnes illétrées
à ne pas confondre avec l'analphabétisme
personnes illétrées sont celles qui ont
oublié l'apprentissage donc il faut
prendre le mal à la racine et quoi de
plus simple qu'effectivement que de
faire participer les enfants de manière
très active donc on leur propose une
sélection de plusieurs ouvrages en au
total il y en avait quatre ou cinq en en
compétition et nous sommes arrivés en
fait deux euh execo h moi et un un autre
auteur et les enfants donc liseent
votent argumentent surtout donc
s'implique réellement après ça leur
donne le goût de la lecture oui j'ai eu
vous avez échangé avec eux aussi je suis
allée à la rencontre de plusieurs
d'entre eux dans dans plusieurs classes
et lors de la remise du Prix j'ai vu
également des parents j'ai vu une maman
qui m'a dit quelque chose qui m'a
beaucoup touché elle m'a dit vous savez
mon fils ne disait que des mangas et
maintenant il a envie de passer à autre
chose voilà c'est un roman fantastique
la mort y est évoquée avec humour avec
un personnage un polter geast fcétieux
qui ent un collège exactement donc le
héros est un cancre de haute envergure
s'est fait renvoyer de son collège donc
son père le met en pension au château de
mil pertui qui est spécialisé dans la
scolarisation des cancres et son
meilleur ami va de est en fait un petit
fantôme de son âge mais qui est mort ça
fait 60 ans voilà et qui entre ce
collège et d' vous vient cette idée je
ne sais pas elle est née comme ça dans
votre imagination non quand j'étais
petite je rêvais d'avoir un ami
invisible un fantôme c'était merveilleux
Casper voilà Casper pour ami plus il est
plus beau que Casper quand même Casper
il a une suite déjà qui a été écrite
alors le le roman a très bien marché
j'ai eu de très bons retours de lecture
donc la suite est sortie ça fait
quelques jours je vous la montre c'est
le fantô du Reich voilà je vais vous
l'emprunter pour le présenter à la
caméra celui-ci la suite donc de cet
ouvrage le château de mil pertui le
fantôme le fantôme du rage ça met en
scène le fantôme d'un ancien officier
nazi qui revient pour finir le travail
en sachant que l'un des personnages
principaux est une jeune fille juive VO
c'est une saga à la Harry Potter que
vous avez Ener du tout je ne sais pas si
je vais avoir l'endurance de de J
Caroline c'est pu c'est pas du tout le
le même univers en fait je me contente
de faire des fins ouvertes à chaque fin
de livre pour pour me laisser la
possibilité ou non de continuer a priori
je devais je n'aurais pas dû faire de
suite pour le château de M pertu c'est
devant l'engouement des des élèves ça a
bien plu ça a bien plu ça m'a
stimulé donner du courage pour m'atteler
à la suite là je suis sur d'autres
projets donc s'il y a un troisième tome
on verra mais ça sera pas pour tout de
suite votre maison d'édition est basée à
Montfort laamie elle est spécialisée
dans la jeunesse oui pourquoi ce ch de
la jeunesse parce que quand on écrit
pour les enfants tout est possible voilà
c'est c'est on a pas de barrière on a
pas de limite on peut avoir un meilleur
ami fantôme on on peut habiter on peut
voyager sur un nuage on peut vraiment
faire faire ce qu'on veut et depuis que
l'année dernière je me suis donc ouverte
à d'autres auteurs et c'est c'est très
bien comme ça ils apportent toutes leurs
compétences à parce que vous étiez venu
sur ce plateau pour nous parler du
lancement de de cette maison d'édition
qui été fondé qui est très jeune encore
he qui a 3 ans on on entame on entame
bravement la la 4e année et ça vous a
permis d'éditer vos ouvrages mais ça
vous permet d'éditer des ouvrages
d'autres auteurs aussi AUD absolument
oui maintenant oui j'ai même une
formidable auteur qui vit en en Angola
et qui contribue à plumenire par le
biais d'une saga donc j'ai des auteurs
dans toute la France maintenant et c'est
très bien donc le bilan pour vous est
satisfaisant de cette maison des déc le
bilan est très satisfaisant très
encourageant beaucoup de rencontres de
bonnes ventes qui est essentielle hein
pour la survie d'une d'une toute petite
maison d'édition voilà on va tout de
même le redire hein parce que vous ne
l'avez pas redit mais c'était une
reconversion l'écriture tout à fait j'ai
dans une autre vie j'ai été avocate puis
mère au foyer et maintenant depuis
plusieurs années je suis auteur jeunesse
et plume en herbe à 3 ans c'est mon 4e
bébé puisque j'ai trois autres enfants
en cher et en os par ailleurs
reconversion réussie donc dans la
littérature jeunesse quelle évolution
vous vous imaginez pour cette jeune
encore maison d'édition il y a une crise
économique donc on va être très prudent
on va pas on ne va pas sacrifier la
qualité donc jusqu'à présent j'ai Lita
six ouvrages par an je je n'ai pas
encore arrêté le le planning 2014 donc
j'ai pas mal de projets mais pour
l'instant tout est à l'étude c'est au
niveau financement mais continuer à
faire de belles choses faire travailler
des bons illustrateurs recevoir des bons
manuscrits voilà c'est la c'est mettre
l'acent sur la qualité pour séduire le
public la qualité et surtout une qualité
d'écriture plume en herbe c'est une
écriture dynamique ou alors poétique
rythmée qui doit attirer l'enfant à la
lecture si à la page 2 l'enfant n'est
pas rentré dans le livre c'est fichu
vous nous le dites c'est la crise pour
toutes les entreprises c'est aussi la
crise pour les la diffusion de toutes
ces œuvres il y a beaucoup de
d'enseignes même de grandes enseignes
qui distribuent des produits culturel
qui qui ferme ne serait-ce que Virgine
qui a fermé définitivement ses portes
déjà hier c'est un moyen de diffusion
pour les livres aujourd'hui vous les
distribuez comment vos livbres dans les
libiries traditionnel dans les grandes
enseignes alors voilà l'avantage de la
crise c'est que ça développe des
ressources d'adaptation on ne peut plus
fonctionner comme avant j'ai un
diffuseur qui lui-même a ses propres
difficultés donc moi dès le début j'ai
tablé sur une grosse présence physique
personnelle j'ai la chance d'être mon
propre auteur également donc ça me
permet d'aller en dédicace de faire
beaucoup de salons d'alimenter également
les dédicaces de mes auteurs voilà donc
la présence sur le terra ça permet de
limiter la la casse on ne peut plus se
contenter du circuit traditionnel
libraire plume en herbe c'est 19 titres
dans le catalogue c'est bien ça et donc
c'est deux livres dont l'un a reçu ce
prix de l'Académie de Versailles le
château de mil pertuille et puis à la
suite le fantôme du rage qui est
disponible vous aviez au tout début
lancé l'entreprise au statut
d'auto-entrepreneur oui vous avez
conservé ce statut quel pas du tout je
suis passer en URL car le statut
d'auto-entrepreneur ne convient pas à ce
type d'activité voilà parce que ce
statut d'auto-entrepreneur ce sera
l'objet de la chronique Koo qui va
débuter dans un instant c'était pour la
transition merci à vous c'est très
gentil d'être passé sur ce plate n
parler de vos ouvrages et de de ce prix
décerné par les collégiant de l'académie
de Versailles le prix PEP 78 V ouvrages
que on peut inciter à se procurer pour
les plus jeunes